We're live on location at Stanford
University and joining me today is an
economist,
author,
scholar,
senior fellow at the Hoover Institution
and living legend Dr Thomas Soul.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Well,
thank you.
Good to be with you.
I feel I have to get the gushing out
first.
That way we can focus on the book.
I don't know that there is anyone on
this mortal coil who's writing and
thinking has influenced me more than
you.
So this,
this is truly an honor for me and I just
have to get that out right at the
beginning.
I just hope I have ms dot Lazar.
We'll find out.
I'll let you know at the end.
Um,
so first I thought I wanted to do a
little bit on your history and I want to
focus on your new book,
but I was curious if you have a sense of
the sort of renaissance that your
writing is having right now with young
people because when I tweeted out that
we finally had you on the show and we've
been trying to make this happen for
quite some time.
I mean,
thousands of responses and I had tons of
people just say,
please tell him this,
tell him this.
My awakening was because of Dr.
how all of this are you noticing
something happening right now because of
the unique place where I only know what
people tell me that's even true at
Stanford.
Uh,
I only know what my,
my research assistants told me.
Alright,
well I'll certainly accept that.
Will take my word for it than a.
So I want to talk a little bit about
your history for a bit and then we'll,
then we'll move on to your new book.
A born North Carolina.
Grew up in the bronx to Harlem in
Harlem.
Sorry,
in Harlem.
Uh,
tell me a little bit about some of your
formative years.
Well,
you know,
I thought about is I was doing the
research for the first chapter where I
get into birth order thing now had my,
uh,
my parents,
loot a normal lifespan.
I would have been the sixth trial in the
family.
They died young.
And so I was adopted in infancy,
a family as an only child,
raised as an only child in a home with
four adults.
And in terms of what I found in the
other researcher on birth order,
clearly that was a huge advantage,
uh,
until their misfortune was my good
fortune.
And Moreover,
the family in which I was raised,
moved to New York,
which at that time had a far superior,
uh,
educational system for that in North
Carolina and foster period of what it is
today.
Were you always interested in education?
I mean,
even as got to kill it,
a little kid,
there was nothing in my background that
would put me there.
Uh,
but fortunately when in Harlem,
there was a kid named ready that the
members of the family had run into
before I ever arrived from North
Carolina.
And he was,
he came from a highly educated family,
uh,
and they immediately saw the
implications if they could get him to,
uh,
to,
to sort of mentor me.
And now I had,
I had met Eddie on my own chances.
I would never have seen any
significance.
He was one of the people I pass by,
but of course the,
the,
the adults understood what the future
was like and then thinking about things
that kids don't think about despite the
great worship of a child talkers these
days.
Uh,
and so,
so he,
he took me to a public library and I had
no idea what a public library was when I
was eight years old and I saw all these
books and I had no idea why we were
there when I didn't have any money to
buy one book.
And so what am I going to do with all
these hundreds of books out on the
shelf?
And he very patiently walked me through
the whole thing.
And again,
I was very reluctant to take out a
library card because I didn't know what,
what all this is about that.
But he talked me into it and I,
and I bought a couple of books and
really had I not encountered him,
the entire rest of the story could not
have been the way it was.
I mean,
at some point I would have learned what
a public library was,
but by that point it would be too late.
Yeah.
I mean,
when,
when you start getting in the habit of
reading when you're eight years old,
uh,
that's a different ballgame than if you
had to wait till you're a teenager and
it's too late now.
Dare I ask if you have any recollection
what you might've taken out of the
library at eight years old?
Uh,
one of the books was adopted.
Do little books.
Uh,
I don't know if you even know what those
are.
He could talk to the animals,
Alice in wonderland and uh,
the rest of them.
But,
uh,
I came in on May and there wasn't.
School wasn't open until September,
so I had no one to play with and I was
just bored to tears.
And so I started reading really for the
first time and I got the habit of
reading and on that,
you know,
that made the rest possible.
Yeah.
Were there any other formative things
that happened to you over those,
those younger years?
Yes.
The same fellow.
It was a very knowledgeable about the
school system,
so when I finished elementary school and
they assigned me to a junior high school
in a very bad neighborhood and he told
me that you,
you can get transferred.
And I in fact got transferred to a much
better school.
I had,
I gone to that other school.
Uh,
I again,
the story would have been entirely
different.
Uh,
and I,
one of the,
one of the themes or the early part of
the book here is that there are a whole
number of things you have to come
together and if you don't have all of
those prerequisites,
then whatever good qualities you have
don't matter.
And I mentioned illiteracy that uh,
you know,
in the middle of the 20th century,
something like 40 percent of the adults
in the world was still illiterate.
And so it doesn't matter what the native
talent or any of that came along,
you can't read there a whole lot of,
uh,
occupation.
You just simply can't get into.
So.
And it's pretty clear from all the
reading of yours that I've done,
you put basic education basically is
number one,
right?
I mean,
is that the one thing that you can do as
a human being?
Get educated,
I guess,
although I wouldn't carry it too far
because some of the most disastrous
notions in the world who come from
highly educated people with,
I'm sure high Iq.
So perhaps critical thinking with a
little education.
I am,
I will settle for almost any kind of.
Yeah.
It's so rare these days.
It is oddly rare.
So,
uh,
one of the things that I found out that
was sort of amazing about your history,
you briefly mentioned it right before we
started,
you were a Marxist at one time in your
life.
Most people will find this hard to
believe,
but it is true,
but it's not that unusual.
Uh,
most of the leading conservative
thinkers of our time,
uh,
did not start off as conservative.
You've got a couple of like a Bill
Buckley and George will,
but I'm A.
Milton Friedman was,
it was,
it was a liberal and a Keynesian.
A High Eq was a socialist.
Ronald Reagan was so far left at one
point the FBI was following him,
you know,
uh,
so,
the,
there's a huge movement from the left to
the right as people get older.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm well aware,
as I mentioned to you earlier,
as a former progressive,
I understand that,
that movement in the modern sense.
Do you remember sort of what you were
thinking?
What appealed to you at that time about
artism?
Yes.
I mean,
there was no alternative being
discussed.
Um,
my first job was as a Western Union
Messenger and uh,
I would come home on some nights.
I would take the fifth avenue bus which
cost all of fifteen cents in those days,
but I figured I splurge now and then and
I would drive,
it would go all the way up fifth avenue
past always Lord and Taylor and all
these fancy places,
and then cross 57th street past Carnegie
Hall and down Riverside Drive.
And that was sort of the Gold Coast
area.
And then yes,
I came across this long viaduct and that
turned into 135th street.
Suddenly there were the tenements and I
went into why is this?
I mean,
it's so,
it's so different and nothing in the
schools or most of the books,
uh,
seem to deal with that and walks,
dealt with that.
Uh,
so it's,
it's,
it's like winning an election when
there's only one person running.
So then what was your wake up to?
What was wrong with that line of
thinking?
A facts?
Facts.
We could probably end the interview
right there.
Specifically.
My first professional job,
I was a,
a,
a summer intern at the US Department of
Labor and I realized from dealing with
these people that the US Department of
Labor,
I'm one of my biggest concern was about
minimum wages.
It has been for a long time.
And so my,
my.
At first I thought,
well this is good because all these
people are poor and it'll get a little
higher income and so that,
that'll be helpful.
And then,
uh,
as I studied economics,
I began to see,
well there's the downside.
They may lose their jobs completely.
So as that.
And so I try and I,
when I was at the Labor Department,
I tried to talk about that to them and
eventually I came up with some test of
it and uh,
uh,
when I came up with this test,
how we might test this,
I was waiting to hear congratulations,
you see that it had this and I can see
these people were stunned as oldest
idiot has stumbled on something that
will ruin us all.
And I realized the US Department of
Labor had its own agenda and interests.
Uh,
and that didn't necessarily not
necessarily mean that the were the four
people lost their jobs for minimum wage
and it got higher pay was their highest
priority.
Yeah.
How much longer did you last after that
was?
No,
that was really the turning point.
And then I began to see that all these
government agencies were not,
they have their own institutional
incentives and you cannot say that the
government will step in and do what's
right for these people and whatnot
because they'll do what's right for
themselves.
So I think a lot of people watching this
and I know because I've been so open
about my own sort of awakening,
are going through this right now,
they're realizing that the things that
they've been taught for so long are not
the truth and are not based.
In fact,
when that happened to you and you
started telling other people,
not just the people you were working
with,
be it family or friends,
what kind of pushback did you get
because it was sort of radical ideas in
a way that you were talking about that.
Well,
I actually,
I didn't,
I didn't feel any need to,
uh,
do a lot,
a lot,
a lot of proselytizing.
Uh,
it was enough for me that,
uh,
that I was now beginning to understand
things I hadn't understood before.
And uh,
you noted that in the book I have,
I mentioned minimum wage studies and
really they are incredibly flawed.
There's a whole chapter on numbers,
uh,
and,
and the other thing,
getting back to my personal development.
I mean,
I left home when I was 17.
Uh,
no high school diploma,
no skills,
no job experience.
And I discovered that there was not a
huge amount of demand for people like
that,
uh,
but in retrospect,
decades later when I do research,
I realized that in 1948,
the unemployment rate for black 16 and
17 year olds was nine point four for
whites,
the same.
Asia was 10 point two,
and those numbers are much smaller than
we were used to in recent decades.
Uh,
and there's no serious racial
difference.
In fact,
the blocks in my age bracket we're doing
just slightly better.
Uh,
and of course,
one of the things that the minimum wage
law does is that it creates
unemployment,
raised it to multiples of what it was.
Nineteen 48 was,
it was a special time because the
minimum wage law was passed in 1938.
And in the intervening 10 years there
was huge inflation in the law,
hadn't gotten.
And so for all practical purposes,
there was no minimum wage law.
But had we had these wonderful liberals,
uh,
insisting that I be paid a living wage.
They were supportive.
Family of four,
I would have been unemployed.
And I don't,
I don't know what that would've looked
right.
It wouldn't probably would not have led
up to everything else.
So when you,
when,
when you think about these wonderful
liberals as you just said,
you know,
I think there's sort of two lines of
thinking.
One is that,
you know,
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions.
I try not to a highway.
It's a super highway.
Exactly.
I try not to besmirch their intentions,
but then I think there are people that
are either can have confused thinking or
have ulterior motives or what else?
What do you think it is as someone that
is so based,
in fact,
and we're going to get to a plenty of
that fact in a moment.
What do you think the thinking is the
flaw in that thinking?
Oh,
I think it's the idea that you don't
have to check a good sounding idea
against what actually happens.
Uh,
the whole 90 zero people to this day who
thinks that the 19 sixties was just a
great period and a,
and I'll send them.
Do you realize how many good trends
there,
the,
the murder rate among black males had
gone down,
it had been going down for two decades,
you know,
by 18 percent in one decade,
22 percent in the next decade,
and in 1960 is suddenly it takes a uturn
straight up and that was not peculiar to
blocks or even to the United States.
A pinker's book about,
about,
uh,
violence that,
you know,
that throughout what the Western world,
the homicide rates did a uturn in the 19
sixties.
So the question is what actually happens
when you put your wonderful ideas to
work?
Do they produce the kind of thing you
thought they were going to produce or
the produce all the opposite and many
errors and they produce lots of
opposites.
Yeah.
I'm glad you mentioned Steven pinker.
I had him on the show a few weeks ago
and I think he's,
you know,
he's one of the clearest thinkers we
have and you know,
his new book enlightened me now is that
things are trending more positively,
but even hearing that is,
is very hard for a lot of people.
Well,
it depends on what your baseline is,
a pancreas much more optimistic than I
am.
Uh,
I,
uh,
I happen to be very pessimistic about
the future,
but I hope the optimists are right.
Do you think you're a pessimist by
nature?
No,
but I think having studied with so many
things that sounded so good and ended up
so bad,
uh,
it makes me a doubt,
especially when there are people who are
anxious to spout off with very little
study of what,
of what they're talking about.
Yeah.
We've got a lot of that these days.
Do you think that has ramped up or.
Yeah,
I think social media seems to amplify
things,
but do you think it's always been that
way about just sort of this endless
pontificating of people that really
don't know what they're talking about?
Well,
there's always been that as long as
there have been human beings,
but the question is magnitude of it and
the ability of various institutions to
shut out on any other viewpoint of which
the universities are the worst examples.
Yeah.
That,
uh,
I mean,
when I,
when I see the riots with Charles Murray
shows up and I have a notion I was
blurry.
I mean,
if you can demonize wherever you can
demonize anybody.
Yeah.
I mean,
and uh,
and I,
I listened to see what are they going to
quote that he said,
I've never heard a single quote of all
the books the man is written.
They,
they never caught anything he said.
And a lot of what he said is the direct
opposite of what they claim.
He said that tells you a little bit
about state we're in right now.
So,
so this,
this thing that's happening on college
campuses right now that everyone seems
to think it's freezing free speech and,
and it seems to be speeches,
speech that's generally thought of as,
right?
So it's conservatives,
Libertarians,
further people on the right than that.
You're saying that's really not a new
phenomenon,
you,
you were kind of.
Well,
it was not that bad in the 19 fifties
when I was a Marxist.
And when Senator Joe McCarthy was Kara
was tracking down anybody on the left.
But uh,
I said whatever I felt like where I
arrived,
felt like it and I got no such blow
back.
That's really interesting.
So McCarthy's talking about all this
stuff,
but you had no problem being an open in
Washington.
I was in Cambridge,
so be it.
Yeah.
So you do think of something has gotten
worse now?
Oh No,
there was a number of things.
Venereal diseases,
for example,
we're going down a very steep worried it
was either syphilis or gonorrhea that
was one half or as prevalent in 1960 as
it was in 1950.
That brilliant idea was to bring in sex
education,
you see,
to avoid unwanted pregnancies and so on.
And a venereal diseases skyrocketed.
Unwanted pregnancies,
teenage pregnancy skyrocketed.
It's amazing that so many people on the
left are able to just ignore any facts
that go against their theory.
Yeah,
it just does not.
Uh,
my uh,
my old mentor at the University of
Chicago,
a joy stigler argued however,
that economists have early influence and
what they,
what they say makes very little
difference.
And he was giving a talk at the hoover
institution wants.
He said,
thanks to years of dedicated work by
Tom,
so,
uh,
the next minimum wage increase will be
five cents an hour less than it would
have been otherwise.
Well,
that's what's interesting to me is
because,
as I,
as I prefaced this with you,
I think that the writings that you've
done all these years and these books,
they're becoming culturally relevant
maybe in a way that they weren't,
I don't even want to say it this way,
but maybe in a way that they didn't,
weren't economically relevant.
Why do you understand the point there
that I think there's a cultural
relevance to all the things that you've
done for these last 40 some odd years
that seems so actually powerful and
impactful to me right now,
which is incredible when it comes to the
impact that that's a different story
entirely.
I mean,
long ago I stopped accepting invitations
to testify before a congressional
committees.
It's an absolute waste of time.
They have made up their minds and they
just want to be able to say they've
heard all points of view and then it
pretty much stops there.
That's right.
And I,
I remember once or Kenneth Clark was,
I was debating him and he was beside
himself because of the mindset,
supposed sinister influence in
Washington during the Reagan
administration.
I told him if my,
if my influence in Washington is all you
have to worry about,
very fortunate,
bad because I've had,
I can't think of anything that happened
any different than if I had never said
anything to anybody that you're being
very humble sir.
No,
I'm realistic.
I mean,
I,
I can't,
I can't find it.
I can remember testifying before one
committee and uh,
the audience was so rowdy that the
chairman had to bang the gavel to keep
them shut.
The shut them down and they put some
little tiny thing in the law.
They were building a.
and I would bet their rent money that,
that provision is gone now because there
was so many people who did,
who didn't,
why?
I was saying that if you're going to
help up for kids,
then give the money to the kids.
You know it.
For where,
where were they go.
Don't turn it over to the institution
because they will then use it in an
entirely different way.
Are there any examples where the money
is turned over to the institution?
Whatever the institution might be,
where it really does work?
Are there any aberrations?
There must.
There must be somewhere by the law of
averages,
but a is not prevalent.
Yeah,
so a couple of times you've mentioned
liberals and one of the things that I
talk about on my show offing because I
wa,
I was a progressive.
I was,
I was a lefty.
I now call myself a classical liberal
and I've tried to make the point that
being a liberal in the traditional sense
has very little,
if anything to do with the left anymore.
Yes.
Are there any,
do you see any sort of meaningful
distinction between classical liberal
and Libertarian at this point or,
or DC even?
I'll ask you a couple things at once and
you can go any direction.
Um,
do you see any,
are there,
do you see a difference?
Of course between liberals and the left.
I mean the words have all sort of
afraid.
When I used to always say that he was,
he was a liberal Senator Hyatt,
and of course in different countries,
the word means different things in
Australia.
Uh,
if you said you were a liberal that they
would understand what you saying,
but in a liberal and is Australia is
different from a liberal in the United
States.
So when you say liberal,
you mean leftist basic.
The American sense of the word.
Yeah.
Um,
what do you think there's any sort of
real distinction that needs to be made
between classical liberal and
libertarian that that's one of the
things that people ask me all the time
and I know you're not big on labels
generally,
but I did read something where you said
that the closest thing that you could be
labeled as his libertarian,
is that still where you're at accept a
course in foreign policy?
We can talk about that too.
And I mean,
I guess also the Libertarians seem to
have this atomistic view of the world,
which I think is a completely
unrealistic.
Yeah.
So it's a good because not only in my
life,
but in the lives of people around me,
uh,
the surroundings might make a huge
difference.
Uh,
one of the things I get into a lot in
the book is this,
the disparities imply either either
discrimination on the one hand or
genetic differences on the other.
And disparities are the norm.
I mean,
I was just reading something the other
day,
you know,
that,
uh,
Latin America has eight percent of the
people in the world.
They commit 38 percent of all the
murders and in Latin America at 80
percent,
no 30,
38 percent for that.
But in Latin America,
80 percent of the murders occur on two
percent of the streets.
Wow.
So,
but you find that when you look,
look up facts,
that's what you find over and over
again.
Uh,
and,
and in all the discussions of a income
differences,
they acted that day.
They never take into account.
Age and age is huge.
I mean,
Japanese Americans have a median age of
50 Hispanic Americans has immediate age
of 26.
Now,
when you see a Hispanic Americans
greatly overrepresented among baseball
stars and not a single Japanese American
baseball star and the major leagues,
I don't believe in the entire history.
Well,
we had each hero on.
No,
no,
no.
That was.
There are people of Japanese ancestry
who've come baseball stars.
All of them are from Japan.
None of them are Japanese American.
Okay.
Fair enough.
Right.
He played,
he was a star in Japan for that.
That's right.
Yeah.
Uh,
so,
so how many 50 year old men are going to
be baseball stars?
Uh,
and by the same token,
how many 20,
26 year old men are going to be surgeons
or ceos,
uh,
any other kind of job that requires long
years of study or,
and slash or long years of experience.
And so even if they were the same,
the two groups were the same in every
other way.
And if there was absolutely no
distinction though,
discrimination and whatnot,
they still would be a huge difference in
income simply because of age.
And that really is what this book is
about.
And you know,
the book itself,
it's about 160 pages,
but what I loved,
you know,
how many pages of notes you have in
there,
do you have,
do you know,
off hand veins,
127 bay pages are texts and the rest of
it as notes.
So you had about 30 some odd pages and
notes and I actually started going
through the notes because I thought this
is,
this is exactly what we need now.
We,
you know,
like when I was reading it,
there were pages that I had to read more
than once because you're obviously
giving a lot of numbers and facts and
you have to look at these things from
different angles and we're not very good
at that these days.
Right.
We're,
we're sort of from one angle and then
you start the screaming and I think
that's what you're,
you're really a master up here.
Yeah.
Well thank you.
I'm trying,
I try to but we'll see.
We'll see how it works out.
We'll see.
Um,
do you make any meaningful distinction
between sort of a classical liberal and
a libertarian?
Is that,
is that just sort of a,
that's a wholly peripheral as far as I'm
concerned.
I'm just trying to get a few simple
facts that crosses a full time job.
Yeah.
All right.
So now let's talk about some of the
facts that you learned in the back.
You talk about two types of
discrimination.
Uh,
could you,
could you lay those out in the world has
almost opposite meetings.
I mean the first meeting when they say
you have someone has discriminating
tastes,
you mean he,
he can tell what is a good wine from a
bad wine,
what is a good camera from a bedroom and
so forth.
And that's almost the exact opposite of
the meeting and the law where you mean
someone who judges someone by what group
he comes from irrespective of the
individual's actual personal qualities.
So those are two very different things.
Uh,
ideally you would like every person to
be judged as an individual,
but as a practical matter,
that becomes impossible because the
costs are prohibitive.
Yeah.
I use the example where if you're
walking down the street at night and you
see a shadowy figure in,
in an alley up ahead,
I mean,
do you judge him as an individual or do
you cross the street and go across on
the other side because,
uh,
the cost of,
of judging him as an individual can be
very high including your life.
So,
uh,
so we make that distinction,
but then I say that I call that
discrimination discrimination.
One one is when you just have a,
a,
a very good understanding of what the
facts are.
And so if you judge these persons and
individually I call that discrimination
one a and then if you judge them by the
group they belong to,
that's not as good,
but that's discrimination wouldn't be,
but it's still based on some facts,
uh,
discrimination tool,
which is one reason we have anti
discrimination laws is that you don't
worry about that at all.
And he's someone that you don't like for
whatever reason.
Uh,
then you,
uh,
you know,
you're biased against them.
Yeah.
Are you shocked when you look at what's
going on right now?
And see so much talk about race all the
time.
So much talk about all of the things
that separate us,
the very things that you've been arguing
against based in fact for so many years
that seemed in an odd way more.
I don't think there's more racism now
than ever or more of dividers,
but there's more talk about it.
Yes.
And it's devastating.
I mean a was in general a much easier to
start than they ought to stop.
I mean,
when,
when that a fellow in,
in,
uh,
in Serbia shot the archduke,
I mean,
who knew that that was going to millions
of people around the world,
including people from the United States
about to about 10,000
miles away and I called with and start
shooting the great war and you can't get
in.
You get an a and worried about the
current trade war.
You start a trade war.
You may never be able to stop it.
And then in the next decade,
because there are too many people
involved,
too many cross currents of interests and
so on.
Well,
what would you do about our school
systems?
Oh my goodness.
I'll try,
I'll try to be rational.
Do try.
They are so awful.
Uh,
the public has no idea what I'm reading
a book about the schools and the woman
who writing a Diane Ravitch is talking
about how teachers have due process
before they can be fired.
Now know when you look into the facts of
it right down here,
and I think it was afternoon the,
it cost a half a million dollars to fire
one incompetent teacher,
uh,
you know,
you,
you don't have a big enough budget.
You know,
New York,
he has something called the rubber room.
This is the teachers who is so
incompetent that the principals don't
want them in the classroom,
you know,
and they get paid full salary and they
show up and they accrue a pension rights
and so forth.
And the last time I forget how many
millions of dollars I spent a year in
New York paying for teachers who don't
teach and in fact don't do anything but
show up at at the same time as if they
were teaching and they read magazines or
whatever.
They feel like doing a.
and this forest goes on a,
at a time when they don't have enough
money to provide the kids with a decent
supply.
So how do we scale back this?
I mean,
you can talk,
we can talk about it through the lens of
education,
but in any mna area where the government
has taken on a bigger role than it's
supposed to do,
I think one of the things you hear all
the time is it's sort of too late.
I think a lot of people think it's too
late to take back.
No government power.
No,
you heaven's a during the Reagan
administration.
That was the only time I know of when
the Federal Register grew.
Smaller that where they compile all the
laws that had been passed in a given
time.
So it can be done.
It's not,
it's not,
it's not.
Uh,
it's not easy,
but it can be done.
Someone wants to.
There was some issue with Reagan was
discussing and someone said,
you know it,
it's complicated.
He says,
not complicated.
It's just not easy to do.
I mean,
right now we,
I,
one of the big forces out here or talks
about affordable housing and they're
appointing a blue ribbon committee is to
look into why there's no affordable
housing and I think that that's,
that's like appointing of Blue Ribbon
Committee to,
to,
to explain why the ground is wet after,
after a rain.
I mean it's very simple.
If you prevent people from building
housing and the population is growing,
you're going to have a housing shortage
and you won't have affordable housing.
It's really,
you know,
economics one during the first,
first two weeks.
They're not very good at taking
economics,
widow and I don't think so.
So when you're answering,
be in almost every case to just scale
back government scale back regulation,
it depends on what they're doing there.
There were some things,
uh,
the government is necessary to do.
So what,
what are those types of things that you
done for security?
First of all,
having,
having dependable laws up.
Some people think that if you're a,
a for free,
that means you don't think the
government should do anything.
No,
you get the free markets don't operate
except within a framework of laws that's
wholly different from having them
operate with politicians jumping in
unpredictable times to suddenly pass
some new legislation.
Yeah.
What can we do right now?
I mean,
so really this would be about just sort
of electing more libertarian minded
politicians then.
I mean,
is that really the only way we can
change things,
do you think?
No,
I think the main thing people have to
know what the facts are themselves.
Uh,
if,
if everyone knew what all the facts
were,
I think you'd have an Italian different
set of set of people elected.
I,
I can't believe that either of the
presidential candidates in 19 in 2016,
uh,
would,
would have been the candidates if you
had an informed public.
We're not very good at that.
How much of this do you think is part of
the media's fault?
That's one of the things was the media
are mostly uninformed.
No,
no.
They're not uninformed or misinformed.
Uh,
and,
and they simply do not shut.
Check the facts on the large issues of
small.
Yeah.
What,
what can we do to fix that,
do you think?
I mean,
I suppose this,
no,
but I buy books like this as well,
but I think more fundamentally the
public that votes has to itself become
informed and not be so easily stampeded
by slogans in a few numbers thrown
around.
Like,
you know,
women make x percent of what men make
and so on.
Yeah.
Uh,
when I started studying that some years
ago,
for example,
uh,
I found out that a young,
young female doctors made much less
money than young male doctors not seem
like a very odd.
And so I.
But when you're looking into it,
you discover that young male doctors
work an average of 500 hours a year or
more than young female doctors and they
get paid for the 500 hours.
But,
but there,
there's no reason why the women and men
should be doing the same thing.
Their circumstances are different.
So are there any laws that are in place
right now that you believe are
discriminatory one way or another
toward,
towards any community or against any
community?
I would have to write a much larger book
to cover them all the minimum wage laws,
absolutely devastating,
uh,
the policy of saying that you cannot
have more kids from one ethnic group
disciplined in the school and from
another is nonsense.
I mean groups are different for each
other and umpteen ways and then just
have the presumption that they are the
same except the way they're treated a is
nonsense.
It's never been true.
And I don't know why we would think is
true here today.
So I do sense that some of what you just
said there is bubbling up into the
national conscience because I get a ton
of email from black conservatives now.
People that feel that they haven't been
represented fairly or that the,
the,
you know,
the so called leaders of the black
community that are on television all the
time are actually preaching the complete
reverse of everything that you've said
here.
Do you sense that there is some sort of
growing conservative movement,
black community?
There was a time when,
when,
uh,
that community with a consistent of
million.
Walter Williams,
uh,
I know all these to say we were the
tuition of a fly on the same plane,
otherwise a whole will disappear.
Disappeared,
goes down.
Well,
I mentioned to you before we started
that Larry elder caused my awakening
because I was a progressive and I said
something to him about a systemic racism
on air and he beat me senseless with
facts and I had to go back and reassess
what was wrong with my thinking.
Well,
you know,
in one,
in one of the,
in one of the chapters,
the,
I have a little section about,
uh,
the era of apartheid in South Africa.
And I had that in there because there's
so much argument.
How much racism is there,
soap when I say let's test this
hypothesis in a setting where there's
absolutely no doubt is a,
a Raga and that's apartheid in South
Africa,
uh,
with the government where blacks were
not allowed to vote,
so forth.
And you then apply the economic
principles and you find that the
economic principles apply in South
Africa that,
uh,
there were some occupations.
See,
blacks weren't allowed by law to be in
certain occupations,
is more than a certain percentage and in
some occupations couldn't be hired at
all in some of those occupations where
they couldn't be hired at all illegal to
hire them at all.
There were more blacks higher than the
whites because there are economic
factors that could come in and you don't
just pass a law and not automatically
produces the results you want.
Yeah.
Can,
can you go into some of the economic
factors that you mentioned there?
Because I thought it was sort of
interesting about the types of jobs that
I had and why that would affect.
Well,
it's no,
it's the competitiveness of the industry
and the competitive industry.
A discrimination and then the,
in the sense that we use for entity
discrimination laws,
uh,
it costs the discriminator as well as
the others.
Now in so far as the price can be
invaded by the discriminated,
he will,
he will describe,
for example,
minimum wage laws let,
when you have a minimum wage law,
you have more people applying for jobs
in those categories than there are jobs
available.
Because the raising,
the raising the wage rate cause more
people to apply and employers to hire
fewer because if more expensive and so
you have a chronic surplus.
Now if you've got a chronic surplus in
an industry,
it costs nothing to discriminate but it
and but it.
But if you have a competitive market,
then of course it does cost something
that for every person that you
discriminate against those qualified,
you've got to hire somebody else and you
got to raise that paved cap rate in
order to get people in.
So I show how how competitive industries
have much less discrimination than say a
regulated public utilities.
I was wondering when I was reading it,
if you were ever going to talk about how
now technology is also changing this,
so we see a lot of these movements for
$15 minimum wage and I know why you
don't think that's a great idea,
but even now where we see Mcdonald's and
some of these other places just
replacing people with IBS and computers.
This,
this has been happening.
I don't know,
when I grew up in Harlem,
when you went into a movie theater,
this is a little neighborhood movies,
theater in Harlem.
There would be a kid who would walk by
down the aisle with you with a
flashlight and show you to your seat.
And so now,
now that we have so many compassionate
people who want people to be paid a
living wage,
you actually stumbled down this down the
aisle to your seat the best way you can
because they're not going to pay that
kind of money.
You know,
the that's unrelated to productivity.
What would you say to the people I hear
a growing movement of people saying,
well,
this is why we need a universal basic
income because technology is going to
force for so many people out of the
workplace.
Oh,
that has,
that is that the island has been made
for centuries and has been proven wrong
for centuries.
Uh,
I would ask the question,
what has happened?
We've moved in that direction already.
We have lots of people who can live off
the welfare state and not and not and
not have to be productive.
Uh,
and how,
how are they better people as a result
of that?
Uh,
one of I saw some time back and have,
haven't follow this,
that a young pete,
the suicide rates among young people
were among the negative consequences of
the 19 sixties,
uh,
people,
you,
you've taken all meaning out of people's
lives.
And so they find all kinds of crazy
things to do drugs,
whatever.
Uh,
and again,
it's not peculiar to the United States
and you find this in Britain,
other countries.
Uh,
and so again,
people who say this almost never look at
any facts about what's happened as we
expanded the welfare state,
that people behave better.
No,
you know,
I mean,
when,
when one of the,
one of the things that one was that I
remember very well when I was,
I was back in the school in Harlem for
some reason maybe doing research and I
looked out the window and I said,
said,
you know,
when I was a teenager,
I used to walk a dog,
my dog in that park.
And look,
it look so hard.
I came up with the students' faces
because that was,
that was a different world.
And so,
uh,
and,
and when I tell them that I used to
sleep out on the fire escape on hot
summer nights,
but who,
who could afford air conditioning and
they think I'm a man from Mars.
People did that all over New York.
They did it in Washington.
They did it in North Carolina.
Relatives in Washington used to go down
and Haynes point down here,
the Jefferson memorial on hot summer
nights and sleep there.
So sometime after midnight when,
when the,
when the heat wouldn't be so bad and
he'd go home at that time,
it'd be out of your mind to do that
today would be too dangerous.
Yeah.
So how do we sort of untie some of this?
So my sister right now lives on the
upper west side in Manhattan,
not too far from Harlem and she's in a
half a rent stabilized or rent
controlled building and,
and half market price.
She's on the market price.
So she's paying to be in a bedroom in
New York City.
I don't even want to tell you how
expensive it is,
but then there are basically half of the
building that's paying next to nothing
and that of course incentivizes people
not to get off the Dole because if
you're living in a nice area on the
upper west side,
very cheap.
Why in the world would you ever get off
the Dole?
How do we start solving these problems?
And I know,
I know facts is your is your bedrock ans
yes,
but,
but what can we do to get people to
understand some of this stuff?
Because it's easy.
It seems so basic to understand.
If someone was giving you something that
you didn't earn this,
this again is,
this is common in Europe and England
especially is a,
it's a,
it's a special problem because you have
the,
you have this place where your rent is
subsidized and say you're in London and
jobs are disappearing in London and they
opening up in Manchester.
Now,
if you go to Manchester,
you know,
you don't,
you get on a waiting list for that kind
of,
uh,
as you stay in London,
you're unemployed,
which rent is low,
and so pete,
you,
so you slow down the movement of people,
you slow down the turnover of people in
these apartments.
But again,
most people who talk about this don't
even talk in terms of if this then that
they talk about it is,
this is how the world ought to be.
Well,
heck,
I can think of all kinds of things we'll
have,
I think the world ought to be.
But unfortunately most of those things
involve a cost trade off.
Do you think there is a system or a
government that's doing it better,
doing freedom better than we're doing it
here for,
for all the flaws that we have in this,
in this system?
Is anyone doing it better than us?
Although there may be marginally solved,
but I think most of the Western world is
less free than it was,
say 30 years ago,
40 years ago by,
by what measurements do you view that?
Oh,
just the amount of regulations.
Uh,
things you could use,
and also by consequences.
I was reading a Milton Friedman,
he and his wife had a joint
autobiography and she,
she's looking at one point,
she says,
looking back on the days when she would
ride the ind subway in Manhattan and
what a joy it was.
And she said it knows long gone days and
uh,
the ind subway goes through Harlem and
Milton Friedman and his wife when they
were still according used to go dancing
at the savoy ballroom.
A very,
very few people want.
And you know,
the famous theme song of Duke Ellington,
take the,
a train the,
a train goes right through Harlem on the
I and D line.
And uh,
so Friedman who was only five foot two,
he had no fear of being mugged or even a
costume.
And go there.
There were.
And this was common,
there was a,
there was a black actress who used to
get finished with Pele and her
socializing afterwards at 1:00
in the morning.
She said she would be taking the subway
up to 155th street and St Nicholas
Avenue by herself.
And one walking home,
nobody does that these days.
And so you have to look one at what are
the facts,
how did they change?
And,
and,
and he don't simply say the other thing
is that the same,
the no child left behind thing with
Bush.
There are kids who go to school to raise
hell.
And a handful of those can present the
whole classroom learning anything.
Now the logical thing would be to
separate those kids out.
And the ones who want to learn
something,
learn something.
You can't do that because the ideology
says no.
And he goes,
so and so you sacrifice whole
generations of poor and minority kids
for this ideology and this utopian
notion.
Yeah.
And we.
And we ended up in an ID,
dystopia.
Probably Friedman used to say,
uh,
the best is the enemy of the good.
And of course it would be better if
everybody could be educated at the same
time.
It can't be done.
So as someone that has survived the
arrows and,
and the venom that the left can throw at
you,
because I see a lot of this these days.
I see even when they,
they say to me,
um,
I find I get a lot of email from people
saying,
well,
how,
how can I be brave enough to do it?
And I think it's particularly a unique
situation for a minorities that consider
themselves conservative or libertarian
or a little bit to the right.
So I mentioned Larry elder before and of
course you and my friend David Webb and
I,
you know,
there,
there are some more black conservatives
than perhaps there used to be.
Um,
no question about what would be if
someone's watching this right now and
just needs that little extra bit of
courage to start saying,
no,
no.
You have to look at the circumstances.
I mean,
I've advised some young people,
uh,
do not go into,
ended up teaching in public schools
because,
uh,
the odds are so stacked against you and
people can write bad references from
you.
For you,
when you touch him,
when you're young and you,
and what they say about you is all of
this someone sees now,
by the time I was a teaching at some of
these schools,
I remember one place where the
department,
she haven't used to threaten one of my
colleagues who,
he wouldn't write good rob references
for him.
I had,
uh,
you know,
I'd,
I'd published stuff while I was still in
graduate school.
I had Milton Friedman and enjoy joy,
stealing the right references for me.
What this guy said there as chairman of
the department wouldn't,
wouldn't matter a bit,
but,
but most people don't have,
don't have that,
uh,
situation.
And so you have to pick you,
you have to pick your fights.
So I want to,
uh,
time is limited here.
I want to mention one thing that you say
right at the end of the book that really
what we need more than anything else
perhaps is common decency.
And we've Kinda lost.
That isn't common anymore.
I mean,
uh,
when I was going to school and we'd have
fights on the school yard grounds,
when one guy was clearly a beaten,
whoever was the toughest kids in the
crowd,
which simply step in and stop it.
The other guys said,
you want to fight,
you can fight me.
You know,
that's what we needed in the public
square.
Now.
Yes,
yes.
But,
but what I mean the,
there's only so much the police can do
if you,
if you don't have common decency that
the cops are not,
not,
not going to be able to,
to handle it,
especially in when everyone is second
yesterday.
I love it when people who have never
fired a gun on their lives,
uh,
say,
why did the cops fire so many guns now?
At one time I taught pistol shooting in
the Marine Corp.
It doesn't surprise me in the slightest
shots fired so many things under those
conditions,
but people,
people can't be knowledgeable about
everything,
but they can be knowledgeable about the
extent of their own ignorance or even if
they have phds.
Sarah,
thIs has been a true honor and a
pleasure.
And I know I can see it in your eyes,
even the,
the sort of humility that you have in
humbleness,
but you've,
you've affected so many people and are
still continuing to affect so many
people.
And I hope that we might have just given
that a little extra bump today.
So I'm,
I'm truly honored that you took the
time.
Thank robots.